في بريطانيا اسوا ازمه اضرابات تشهدها
قطاعات عده في البلاد ابرزها قطع النقل
والصحه والسما خوف حكومه ريشي سوناك من
عدم القدره على احتواء الوضع وبدات طواقيم
فرق الاسعاف الاضراب عن العمل يتسع الخلاف
مع الحكومه بشان رفضها زياده الاجور بعد
اضرابات الممرضين الاخيره
النقابات التي تمثل كلا من ممرضات الخدمه
الصحيه الوطنيه
الاسعاف هددت بتنفيذ مزيد من الاضطرابات
في العام الجديد ما دفع مسؤوليه الرعايه
الصحيه الى التحذير من اجهاد النظام الصحي
يعاني بالفعل ازمه كبيره في السنوات
الاخيره هذا وتوعد عمال سكك الحديديه
وشلطه مراقبه الجوازات بايضا بافساد عطله
الاعياد
في ظل رفض الحكومه قبول المطالب المتعلقه
بالاجور
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]